llegó la mente hablar de economía quién
france24 me acompaña en el estudio
daniela blandón daniela buena noche
bienvenida al gobierno de chile se opone
al tercer retiro de las funciones hola
raúl buenas noches la próxima semana
comienza la discusión en el senado sobre
el tercer retiro anticipado del 10% de
lo que tienen los ciudadanos en su foto
de pensiones pero el gobierno no está de
acuerdo en esta oportunidad medios
locales recogieron declaraciones del
presidente sebastián piñera según las
cuales confirmó que llevará al tribunal
constitucional ese proyecto en caso de
que sea aprobado en un proyecto paralelo
de reforma a la ley de educación el
congreso está analizando la posibilidad
de que sea obligatorio que en todos los
colegios se imparta educación laboral y
de pensiones justamente para que los
alumnos estén bien enterados sobre estos
asuntos tan importante raúl así es danny
argentinas el euro récord en exportación
de soja pues primero digamos que este
país es uno de los principales
productores y exportadores mundiales de
granos en el primer trimestre logró
ventas externas por 5 mil millones de
dólares esto
representa un recorte en valor pero no
en volumen aunque si quedó cerca de su
máximo histórico de 2016 la razón es que
en los tres primeros meses de este año
ha habido un alza significativa en los
precios de los granos y sus derivados en
los mercados internacionales pero
también porque en diciembre hubo
conflictos sindicales en los puertos de
exportación y muchos embarques tuvieron
que realizarse a comienzos de este año
las ventas de maíz y derivados también
estuvieron a punto de registrar su
máximo valor histórico del primer
trimestre de 2020 y lo iban a lograr
este año
daniela cadenas de información porque
google pierde una batalla jurídica en
australia así es raúl de un tribunal
federal australiano encontró que google
violó la ley al engañar a los usuarios
sobre los datos de ubicación personal
recopilados a través de dispositivos
móviles android el juez dictaminó que
entre 2017 y 2018 cuando los usuarios
creaban una cuenta de google y la
configuraban sus herramientas eran
confusas y con eso se logró recopilar
almacenar y usar datos de identificación
personal según él
que tomó la decisión la empresa apelará
la sentencia y los consumidores celebran
las medidas mucho más
este es el primer fallo de este tipo en
el mundo en relación con los datos de
ubicación wifi
creemos que este resultado envía un
mensaje muy claro a las plataformas
digitales de que deben ser sinceras con
los consumidores sobre lo que está
sucediendo realmente con sus datos cómo
se utilizan y cómo pueden protegerlos
daniela batalla de multimillonarios en
la nasa que hay sobre esto
raúl en la nasa ofreció un contrato para
construir una nave espacial y llevar
astronautas a la luna los contrincantes
eran el dueño de amazon y el de tesla y
adivine quién ganó quién ganó la
compañía espacial privada del
multimillonario y la mosca space x que
le ganó este pulso a blue origin de jeff
bezos y sus socios y también se la ganó
al contratista dainese text con una
oferta que finalmente sellaron en dos
mil 900 millones de dólares
la nasa raúl quiere tener un vuelo de
prueba a la luna
posiblemente en 2020
antes de que estos viajes se vuelvan
comerciales en un futuro no muy lejano
creo que la que vivimos en este momento
es la edad de oro de los vuelos
espaciales tripulados la gente no se da
cuenta a menudo miramos hacia atrás a
los años 60 y las misiones a la luna
pero en unos años haremos algo todavía
más ambicioso cristero raúl a ellos dos
tienen algo en común tanto el dueño de
la mayor fabricante de vehículos de lujo
del mundo como jeff bezos es que están
en el top de la lista de
multimillonarios del mundo y sería el
espacio daniela si yo no indicadores
wall street del cerro positivo con
récords renovados para sus índices
impulsados por buenos datos económicos
de este resultado se contagiaron también
las bolsas europeas el principal índice
de la bolsa de fráncfort en alemania
también cerró el máximo histórico y un
buen día para los mercados
latinoamericanos un imparable bolsa de
sao paulo encadenó su quinta jornada en
ascenso y ya para finalizar que nos trae
como cifra el día los grandes bancos de
eeuu terminaron de reportar
resultados del primer trimestre que son
excepcionales
raúl bank of america y morgan stanley
duplicaron sus ganancias y citigroup las
triplicó siguiendo a los buenos
resultados que habían presentado antes
sus colegas así es daniela como siempre
muchísimas gracias entonces por toda la
información económica que tenga usted un
muy feliz fin de semana y nosotros así
es y nosotros nos vemos mañana con más
información aquí en france 24
[Música]